[Musique]
gg je vous écoute messi
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans votre rue
au nom de dieu je viens de découvrir que
le diable en a sûrement dû économiser
assez maintenant pour t'acheter un lopin
de terre donc qui pourrait peut-être bon
acheter un tu cherche à vendre fais-moi
une proposition pour ça
jamais de la vie
pour 4 litres de pétrole brut extrait de
cette parcelle 160 litres d'eau
catastrophique pour tout type et où est
le problème à part le fait que ces
radioactives ou ben laden le cancer
c'est de la blague
[Musique]
je sans toi zone ma propriété n'a pas
prouvé que ces oeufs frais il faut des
îles propose cinquante mille pour
l'ensemble payer en une fois c'est une
arnaque il a flairé quelque chose sonne
sodi une chose sur le fait de
sous-estimer son adversaire quoi elle
fait partie laissez pas tomber monsieur
ce turn je viendrais même servir jusqu'à
tout prendre part que je suis payé pour
ça
en sarre et glorifient non je ne le sais
pas
[Musique]
père combes maire
jean reuilles savez tout depuis le début
ils n'ont absolument rien fait si ce
n'est des bénéfices il n'y a pas que cet
endroit dis moi que tu n'as pas signé
cette vente combien vous demandez tout
le monde a un prix ils essaient de
m'acheter pour 50000 misérable dollars
il ne montrait pas à 60,60 vous savez
combien ils ont gagné en empoisonnant
mater 2 milliard cent millions de
dollars et ça c'est juste sur une année
2 milliard cent millions tu te moques de
moi à leurs six fermes y venait à
remporter une victoire dans ce procès il
créerait inévitablement un précédent la
chasse sera ouverte contre les
compagnies la règle de la valeur nette
actualisée si vous gagnez plus d'argent
en faisant ce que vous faites que cela
vous en rencontrez surtout punissait
pour l'avoir fait alors continue à le
faire des fermiers de ce pays se
suicident tous les jours de la semaine
vous voulez être sur la liste
je crois bien que tu vas pas pouvoir
s'en tirer comme ça lisez les indiens au
chef de la cavalerie
[Musique]